make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we're picking up with decease
part four and I feel like Captain Atom
fans are gonna be a little bit pissed
because this actually reminds me of
Kingdom Come if I'm being honest with
you guys it reminds me a lot of Kingdom
Come
so Saudi ceased as we know is basically
the anti-life equation turned into a
viral form this infected the world and
it was cool to see it used this way
right like the only real implementation
that we saw with the anti-life equation
being used on a global scale was during
Final Crisis and it was really more just
like taking the will away from people
but weaponizing it and turning it into a
system to where it basically creates
zombies more or less is actually pretty
intriguing now we will get some
clarification in terms of what all this
is and how it works but again this sort
of switches over to captain Adam and
again captain Adams always kind of just
been like a government man you know kind
of part of Cadmus and all that kind of
stuff basically like a government guy
but what the world sort of popping off
the way that it is and Captain Adam is
really sort of their ace in the hole
insofar as he's a guy that can go
toe-to-toe with Superman and there's no
real knowledge or guarantee the Superman
is actually survived out there and even
if there was there's no real reason to
believe that Superman would abandon
everything and basically fight on behalf
of the government right and you have
like Amanda Waller and all those folks
there's no reason to believe that and he
wouldn't and so basically they ended up
turning to Captain Atom which being a
powerhouse a man made of living energy
and of himself is a pretty cool thing to
do then what we also end up finding out
here is that Ray Palmer the atom has
actually gone directly into one of these
monsters more or less one of these
zombies and is essentially analyzing the
whole thing in terms of what's going on
inside of it and so as a result of this
of course Captain Atom is sent out
basically said hey look try to curtail
the threat as much as you can and he
does the best he can but then suddenly
we end up realizing what's going on and
this is actually a genius move by Tom
Taylor I never would have thought of
this that what ended up happening here
is that when the atom when Ray Palmer
went into this zombie he was immediately
infected right because he was just
exposed to the to the equation and when
that happened
he came out as the atom and then went
into Captain Atom which is really cool
it's actually a genius idea and
immediately started infecting it the
difference here is that instead of Ray
Palmer killing Captain Atom in the
traditional sense what he actually ended
up doing was quote-unquote destabilizing
him right because he's a being made of
living energy so all you have to do is
destabilize him and then suddenly he
just turns into a giant bomb and that's
why I say is really reminiscent of the
events of Kingdom Come right because in
that story he was ripped open and so it
was like all this atomic energy started
pouring out and that's really what kind
of led to the
conclusion of the story like captain
Adam gets ripped open Superman flies him
into the air as fast as he can oh no
sorry I think it's Shazam who does it uh
well any one of the heroes does it and
basically ends up dying in the process I
think and basically like a kind of
Usher's in a new era of peace for the
world but is it's it's essentially the
same thing like happening Adam is
basically going nuclear he's getting
ready to detonate and kill everyone
and so this it's kind of a cool moment
because then you switch back over to uh
Superman and Green Arrow and the new
Green Lantern if you look at it as each
individual issue it seems like it takes
place over the span of like days or
weeks or something like that but if you
just kind of focus on it in and kind of
look at it as the greater whole almost
like you're reading it in trade it takes
place over the course of hours maybe
five or six hours of house it's like the
beginning of this whole thing and so
when you see it that way no wonder
they're all still hanging out of The
Daily Planet
but of course Superman showing up here
the the real question here is if you go
out there and you just try to start
rescuing people you can be exposed to
like a TV screen or some kind of digital
device and you'll be exposed to the
virus and you'll turn and this is
actually again this is another genius
moment it's a small thing see it's the
small things that make Tom Taylor
stories so cool it's the small little
tidbits that make his story so awesome
because what Superman said is there's no
risk of that because I've been using my
x-ray vision the entire time since this
whole thing popped off and it's like man
that's that's like that's actually
pretty genius right because using his
x-ray vision of course he's able to make
out just enough of the the individuals
costumes or what it is that they're
wearing to know who they are but also
probably just the sound of their voice
different things like that it's small
little things like that as that's why
it's so cool is because it's like they
end up sitting out basically like an SOS
to the world and so you end up finding
out that that like Beast Boy Hawkgirl
Lex Luthor and presumably his sister
Lena like they're alive and it's kind of
like we all need to band together and
try to save the world as best we can
it's a cool moment because then you
switch over to Wonder Woman on thermos
Kyra you know and her talking to to
Hippolyta is just kinda like hey look I
have to do this I can't stay here yes
this is my home and I'm safe here
but like my duty is to protect the world
and of what hero am i if I don't protect
the world and so then you basically end
up having a you know family Superman a
company travel over to Keystone City and
meet with Barry Allen and meet with
Wally West this is a cool thing because
one of the things that they were told
when this whole thing popped off Batman
immediately got a hold of them and said
do not go anywhere go somewhere where
there is no technology of any kind stay
there don't go anywhere and and it's
actually it makes perfect sense right
because if any of the flashes of
the speedsters neo managed to contract
this virus the world would be over like
that
there'd be no survivors your talk about
people who can move up to the speed of
light and if they want to enter the
Speed Force at the speed of light uh and
then if they enter the Speed Force with
us who the hell knows what's gonna
happen right so you're talking about
guys who can vibrate from one dimension
to another so it would be it'd be
catastrophic it would take this global
pandemic and elevate it to becoming a
multiversal pandemic the entire
multiverse would just collapse because
of the speedsters vibrating from one
universe to the next and killing
everything they see I love these little
nuggets man I love these little tidbits
it's so cool to see this and so what you
end up getting of course is is basically
like this sound of thunder right it's
kind of emanating and making its way to
them and that's when you actually find
out you find out that this Giganta right
like one of the villains of Wonder Woman
it's just like a Lhasa woman now of
course she's she's dealt with relatively
quick insofar as like you know the
batwing comes flying out of nowhere and
crashes into or at least she grabs it
and then crushes it now of course once
Superman accompanied shows up Superman
manages to knock her down
Wonder Woman actually goes to killer and
this is one of the things I disagree
with with Superman you know Superman's
like no wait you can't kill her yet
Batman said they're only infected so
maybe there's hope and it's like no
Superman they're gone
like they're dead man it's time to let
go Supes but I get that you're the boy
scout I get there's always a good
there's always a way but sometimes
there's not Homeslice sometimes there's
nothing you can do and you just gotta
let him go the cool thing about this is
the work gets done form when sob or
blows a hole in her head now can we just
all like let's look at this for a second
all right
cyborg fans you're finally getting your
do can we all just say this looks badass
cyborg standing behind like like a giant
woman's head and you just blew a hole in
it like can we just say that's amazing
like it looks awesome it really does
like it looks and see this kind of stuff
is why I love comics man because it's
just it's the tits but it's it looks
badass
like let's not let's let's take a moment
of silence for how awesome this is okay
so having said that this is what we kind
of get the explanation of what it is is
going on right and in what side work
really kind of clarifies here of course
you do have Alfred who shows up and
makes Damian Wayne the new Batman now
this is a pretty sentimental thing one
of the big things when it came to Damian
assuming that the history between this
version of his character and the main DC
Universe history is that he's kind of
been reforming himself after being
trained
just like this heartless assassin you
know bye-bye Talia al Ghul by his
biological mother you know assuming that
that history is still relatively the
same he's always been trying to work to
become the best version of himself and
for Batman to pass down the mantle to
him solidifies a few things one it
solidifies his father's faith in a Bruce
Wayne believes that Damian is capable of
becoming Batman but it also solidifies
the fact that his father's dead that
there's no coming back for Batman that
he's gone he's out of the picture
there's no other members of the bat
family
Damian has last one left and that's kind
of got to be a crushing sensation right
to sit down like to wake up one day and
realize that like you're your surrogate
brothers and sisters are all dead that
your biological father is dead everyone
you know and love is dead shy of Alfred
he's the only guy left and and is it's a
it's a rough thing to see right because
in the midst of all this he just cries
in the arms of Alfred and that's it's
that's what I love about this because
it's so human right like Damian Wayne
seems to be a kid who's so disconnected
from his humanity and you see something
like this and it's just so human and
it's so cool and III dig like I look
this I love writing like this I love
writing the focus is so much on the
character the focus is so much on like
who they are kind of at their core and
so that's when sideward chimes in and
says okay so these guys aren't really
dead in the traditional sense right
they're not like Night of the Living
Dead zombies they're effect similes is
all they are they're facts emily's of
the anti-life equation that the
anti-life equation is exactly what it
stands for anti-life and they will
spread anti-life ie death everywhere
they go now this is Tom Taylor taking
the anti-life equation in the most
literal sense right taking and using it
for its namesake and saying the
anti-life equation is anti life it
exists to basically replace life with
death and again that flies in the face
of the traditional census so I imagine
it'll be some who is who kind of you
know kind of snub at that and say no no
no no that's not what the anti-life
equation is it was never meant to be
that way it just dominates the Wills of
people because that's what Jack Kirby
wanted that's what it needs to be
honestly I don't really care one way or
the other it makes for a cool story but
basically it's a cyborg saying they're
like they're not human anymore there's
no way to bring them back you can't fix
them you can't save them there's nothing
we can do they will find life anywhere
there is life they will find it the only
way for us to do that is to leave here
is to get out of here as that's why it's
kind of crazy because in the midst of
all this suddenly they're met by the
arrival of Hawkgirl who says hey look
captain Adams is getting ready to
explode he's getting ready to wipe
everything out and so as a result of
this captain Adams well as soon as he
soon as he detonates why you got Wonder
Woman he's got Superman they whisk him
up into the air
they can't but when he detonates all of
Washington DC goes with it right so
what's left of the government's gone now
there's no organizing structure or force
anymore there's no real military and if
there is a military they don't know who
they're taking their orders from so
there's no real government left anymore
there's nobody making the decisions all
that stuff's basically gone the outlying
territories Baltimore they're all
basically gone and the last one to be
hit as metropolis and so what this looks
like is seemingly almost everybody's
going to die now if I'm a betting man I
probably bet here that basically the
Green Lanterns gonna conjure a shield
that will protect everyone but
essentially what this will mean is that
everybody in their immediate vicinity is
gone all the heroes that were there are
dead all the villains that were there
are dead and they're gonna have to kind
of go back out into the world and see if
they can save who they can but again
this is Tom Taylor and this is Warren
Ellis I would say it's gonna be
unnecessarily bleak and they're all
gonna die these horridly like these
horrendous radiated deaths you know
where they all die of radiation sickness
or something like that this is Tom
Taylor there's usually light at the end
of the tunnel so I'm curious to see
where this goes
I'm really excited to see how this ends
oh that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here two comments explain make sure
you guys at the sub button to become
part of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]